so if you've made a mistake something
isn't working
stop throwing good money after bad just
move on you know learn the lesson
that you're supposed to learn and then
apply it you can always make mistakes
but don't make the same mistake twice
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy she's won more awards
than well we can mention we'd be here
all day
welcome stephanie
thank you can you hear me you are super
awesome
how are you i'm good how are you gary
thank you andrea for that introduction
that was um
pretty spectacular sounds like something
we do in the ring am i blushing you can
see i'm blushing
not yet but but one thing that uh one
thing to make you blush
as a hardcore wwe fan for my whole life
as andre was doing the intro you know
talking about leadership a lot of times
people whether it's me too black lives
matter they react after the fact
and then there's leadership that reacts
prior to when they're supposed to or
when the lights are on
you know as as andrea was intriguing you
i was smiling because the female
aspect of the wwe universe is so
advanced at this point i want you to
talk about it but what i was thinking in
my mind is like
that is so true because when i was
growing up wendy richter and the
fabulous mula got some spotlight
but there just wasn't that much else and
to watch what's transformed
in the organization um over the last two
decades on this front and even the way
women were positioned and things like
it's just incredible what's happened
please elaborate absolutely well it
really started
with how we started to train and recruit
our female athletes
you know we wanted the most elite
athletes from both a male and female
standpoint and we started training them
the same as the men
and giving them the same opportunities
the same match time
which like anything else the more reps
you have the better you're gonna get
and what happened is at nxt which
started off as our developmental brand
and evolved into our third global brand
the women started really stealing the
show and uh there were chants of this
is wrestling and women's wrestling i
remember so then
on raw and smackdown and this is
actually uh february 2015
we had a women's tag match which lasted
all of 30 seconds in a three-hour show
which was unfortunately the norm
and our audience started a hashtag
called give divas a chance that trended
worldwide for three days
demanding more screen time better
athleticism better story lines better
character development
for our women and uh our our chairman
and ceo
my father you know well gary vincent at
the highest level and said we hear
you keep watching give divas a chance
steph
i'm really curious we have we have some
really interesting you know parallels
with
growing up in a family business just out
of my own curiosity just knowing there's
a lot of different people watching that
are in family businesses
your dad such an icon your your
grandfather
such an icon you know as you would go
maybe for the people that are watching
right now because there's a mix of
entrepreneurs executives there's such a
mix on this show which
kudos to andrea and team for creating
this environment
um when did your dad start listening to
you it's really as simple as that
like knowing your dad is such a force
like how did you
how did you go navigate that like like i
i my dad actually gave me a lot of room
because i got in at 14 and really proved
myself and
even when he was giving me a lot of room
any room he didn't give me for something
that i wanted
was a frustrating point it's family
dynamics how did that evolve for you
where
where your voice became bigger at the
table how was that process for you
because i think within that story and
obviously so many people
know the two of you it might help
somebody who's going through it right
now where
they just can't get their parent to give
them that look
i think i'm still fighting for it
honestly gary it's not like i have a
bigger voice at the table that's for
sure
but i would assume steph and i'm sorry
interrupt it's probably bigger than it
was five or seven years ago to your
point like my dad like
my dad still also in all my accolades
pushes against some of my ideas
you know i respect that i understand
that but i would assume it is a little
bit bigger than it used to be no
yeah for sure you know and i think it
you know it ebbs and flows
and um you know it's complicated family
business is super complicated
especially when you have such a strong
personality as you were mentioning
before in your own business with you as
the boss
when your boss has such a strong
personality and is such an an
icon and you know my dad grew up in a
trailer park and
and he truly lived the american dream
and took what was a northeast regional
territorial business and turned it into
this
global phenomenon 108 countries in 28
languages we have you know the wwe
network one of the first to launch an
ott
service behind netflix and hulu because
he took a calculated risk
betting on himself and his business
fourth most viewed youtube channel in
the world over a billion social media
followers that's that's because of him
and his vision and it takes someone
strong who makes quick decisions you
know to
to hearken back to your previous
conversation and who's just truly driven
but who also listens
and i think 100 percent yeah wouldn't it
be i i i'm sorry to interrupt but i just
want to
i think praise is always fun when you
get to hear it
literally because i realized somewhere
in my 30s that i had the knack of
understanding where attention was
there are very few people in the history
of business
that understood attention better than
your father
whether it was saturday morning whether
it was cartoons
whether it was saturday night's main
event whether it's mtv whether it's
cindy loper or liberace with like
like it's so intuitive to me it's how i
built my
universe like i i would argue that your
father
as an executive from afar analyzing
almost everybody
is one of the great listeners even
though when he talks he talks
with conviction and i'm sure very much
juice and again knowing family
businesses but like
it's funny you said that i actually put
your dad's listening skills at the
height
of modern culture agreed and and he
doesn't just
listen to he listens to fans he listens
to the live audience he listens on
social media
but he also listens to our employees you
know and he's always said you never know
where a great idea is going to come from
so he solicits that that opinion you
know he talks to people he really does
speaking of leadership does um do you
feel that your father do you feel you do
you feel that
your husband are good at admitting
they're wrong i've been thinking a lot
about listeners
listeners actually stunningly don't mind
being wrong
how does that play out in your
leadership style or the other leaders
so for me personally um i am very
transparent
and i own mistakes and i think that
that's really important
um i think that you know there's a
difference between
being wrong and making mistakes and i
know that that's a subtlety in semantics
but i do think human psychology plays
into that
um you know and uh again just going back
to
to vince you know he believes in sunk
cost so if you've made a mistake
something isn't working stop throwing
good money after bad just move on
you know learn the lesson that you're
supposed to learn and then apply it you
can always make mistakes but don't make
the same mistake twice
please excuses are never tolerated
actually this now i'm just uh andre i'm
sorry i'm getting extremely selfish here
everybody's watching i'm sorry
this is i'm just nerding out too much
except genuinely back to like learning
and watching audience
let's give somebody a huge shout out in
your in your career watching the talent
who uh who most pleasantly surprised you
from the raw
human they were when they walked in and
started doing undercards to the
superstar they became
who were you most impressed with where
you're like oh my gosh i'm so proud
of x or y they came here as a young kid
or bushy-eyed or maybe even came from a
different league
and had too much ego and then you watch
them
adjust and become more humble
and like who really really as a talent
did you see
listened whether it was from your dad
you
you know hunter you know or the audience
or
who listened the most in the last decade
or two that you really were incredible
with
like impressed with they listened the
most i mean there's so many stories i
could tell throughout time i mean even
stone cold steve austin who was
you know the ring master and he was
standing at the curtain and he tells
this story of
he was watching somebody in the ring and
i'm not sure who it was and he looked
over it at vince and he said
hey you should really give that kid a
push they really got something
and you know my dad looked back and he
said well all i can provide is the
opportunity the rest is up to him
and austin said that's when the light
bulb went off for him
like oh this is really about me
and my ability to listen and my ability
to grow my brand and i think the talent
that we have today
have more of an opportunity than anybody
ever did before because of social media
because they recognize the opportunity
to build their own brand and their own
voice both
in and outside of the ring because the
more people are engaged with you as a
person as an individual which again i
think is an evolution
you know the more they're going to want
to see you perform or they're going to
want to hear you talk or or see you
you know in the ring but i also think
you know
becky lynch is is a huge i could name so
many drew mcintyre
i mean he was here and then he left and
and he went
he has truly learned so much and matured
you know as an individual to now come
back and be champion
let's uh let's finish with this so many
businesses big and small
pivoting during you know just watching
again
because i have so much more knowledge as
a fan the pivoting that the organization
has done what have you learned about
this 150 days about your organization or
about changing your mind or pivoting
or adjusting or never saying never
what's the biggest learning point uh
because obviously
the way you're producing today is so
different than ever before
what's the biggest insight that you can
learn from the macro
uh well i think for wwe you know we
never went off the air
so we've continued to produce seven
hours of content every single week at a
minimum for our television partners for
usa network and fox
and um you know including our
pay-per-views wrestlemania went from
being at raymond james stadium and what
was supposed to be in front of 80 000
people to being performed in our
performance center which is essentially
a warehouse
and we took it to two days over one with
absolutely no fans in the audience
i think the ability to be fluid
the ability to um you know make changes
quickly
the ability to listen and then sticking
to your mission
and reimagining your business but
staying true to what your mission is and
wwe's mission is to put smiles on
people's faces the world over
it's something that we take very
seriously we've considered a
responsibility to stay on the air to
entertain our fans
in the safest way possible as long as we
can be safe
for our crew employees and performers i
love that steph uh
just a little another fun question how
about you as a as a human
between either e-commerce or your own
media consumption i think all of us
yeah our behavior has changed during
this time is there some is there any
product
you now buy online that's delivered that
you
never considered pre covered and you're
in love with the experience or
is there some show on netflix or hulu
or some app that you're playing with
just you the human being what's a new
behavior a consumer behavior that you
can feel that you've
uh established during this time i've
definitely
uh transitioned more to digital
consumption i think that you know you
can look at all of the trends and
everyone always assumed it was going to
go that way but i think it's pivoted
you know three to five times faster than
you know then would have happened
without covid
and and i'm certainly a part of that
transition when i do watch
you know programming on linear
television now i'm like oh commercial
yeah like where do they come from you
know and and that's not to say anything
against our advertising partners i think
it's going to force the ad
industry really to partner with content
creators in a different way
to bring an experience you know to the
viewers or watchers or fans or
consumers whatever it is that is
additive to them
um versus you know taking away the time
of their viewing it's going to cause us
all to be more creative
i agree i appreciate your time i hope
you
have a wonderful rest of the year and i
can't wait to see you soon
thank you gary i can't wait to see you
too and andrea i called you andrea it's
andrea i i'm correct
she answered all versions
i'm from the midwest so it's really
andrea stephanie okay okay
but but one last thing gary back on the
women's evolution it
ultimately wound up with our women
headlining and main eventing
wrestlemania which is akin to our super
bowl or the world cup
and also having not one but two women's
matches in saudi arabia over the past
two years so i think that's
pretty strong good for you thank you so
much hey everybody on youtube first of
all thank you so much so humbled for
your time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out